at this time I'm delighted to introduce
this year's the student speaker Kevin
Wayne Zach today Kevin is graduating
with university honors from the Dietrich
College of Humanities and Social
Sciences earning a bachelor's degree in
cognitive science with a minor in
software engineering kevin is both an
exemplary scholar and a passionate
student leader a member of the Dietrich
College Dean's List he was inducted into
the Sakai international Honor Society in
psychology he has been a resident
assistant community advisor cabinet
minute member in student government and
a leader in the Greek community also
serving as vice president of community
standards for Interfraternity Council
this past winter Kevin was awarded the
CMU Greek role model award for
excellence in scholarship leadership
service and lifelong friendship
Kevin also served as chair and director
of event logistics and head of marketing
for the Pittsburgh donut dash
[Music]
the annual citywide event has raised
more than 570 thousand in four years to
support ALS research and is among the
largest Greek Fran tropic event in the
nation after graduating Kevin will take
his many talents to Washington DC
working for Deloitte as a consultant for
the federal government please join me in
an enthusiastic round of applause for
the class of 2018 student speaker Kevin
Wayne Zach Kevin
Thank You president Johnny and for the
kind introduction I've had no greater
honor in my life than to be standing
here today graduating with all of you
and our time here we've seen a lot of
change skeebo cafe has become waiting 30
minutes for a sandwich free stones have
become you see stones and we have like a
bajillion more buildings on campus now
than we did before all of this change
marks the end of a long journey of
Education for many of us to those of you
continuing on to even more school well
good luck
when I think back to freshman year
between all of the vote Ellie's pizza
that I ordered the hundreds of times I
walk down Morewood Avenue and the few
tipsy trips down Beeler
[Applause]
someone somewhere told me something that
I don't think I'll ever forget
they said the years that I spend at
Carnegie Mellon are going to be the most
difficult of my life but that everything
after is gonna be easy well at that
point I bet you could guess what I was
thinking yes all I have to do is write a
few lines of code and the Silicon Valley
will be knocking on my door right well
the main point of that completely flew
over my head because I didn't know what
it meant
did it mean that Carnegie Mellon was
going to work me just hard enough that
everything was to be easy in comparison
or that I was going to become so smart
that I could solve any and every problem
well for years we have worked hard to
achieve our goals now I believe that our
time at CMU is difficult because there
are lessons that we learn and goals that
we have that require us to commit and it
is this commitment that Foster's that
Carnegie Mellon spirit of putting our
hearts into our work we committed to
learning these lessons from and with
each other fellow students have taught
me that it is important not to be a
voice for others rather we should use
the voice that we have to bring others
into the conversation I learned that
while we are capable of doing great
things the most important thing that any
of us can be is a great friend we've
learned these lessons and had these
successes because we attended Carnegie
Mellon during wild and historic times in
which it has become clear that diversity
is our strength
we accomplished more when we stand
together
and we committed to doing work that
manifests these lessons I've seen this
commitment in the plains that CMU
students have sent to Puerto Rico in the
gatherings that we've had at the fence
and the late night meetings in my
fraternity I've seen it in the beautiful
expressions of self at community collage
and in the kind actions of you my fellow
students as we support each other
through homeworks and projects that we
absolutely should have started at least
a week ago in order to learn these
lessons in order to do this work we
needed to commit to being tenacious and
to being brave I've seen my peers
demonstrate tenacity while building many
buildings that go up for only a weekend
while raising record-breaking amounts of
money for local charities and and
working with our administration to
improve the student experience I know I
had to be brave freshman year when I
called my mom and I had to convince her
that cognitive science was just as
lucrative as civil engineering making it
here today for many of us is an act of
bravery itself see I have 100% faith
that if we go out into our communities
and keep with us this spirit that
Carnegie Mellon has given us we are
going to continue to learn and change
the world
people sitting in this stadium right now
are going to save our environment when
Oscars and Toni's create art that
changes people's lives some of us are
going to become doctors disrupt
industries cure cancer become the
elected leaders of tomorrow and make
this world a better place
if we can continue to learn from those
who have come before us and teach those
who follow we are going to craft a
future where compassion fuels innovation
and at the very least yet just as
important each one of us has it in us to
be a role model for our younger
generations and the fruits of our effort
they might not be seen immediately
maybe not for five years or ten years or
more but it will still require us to
commit and who knows maybe life after
Carnegie Mellon is going to be easy
maybe it won't be but at least now we
kind of know what we're doing so while
we have all forged our own paths to
arrive at commencement today we have
converged for what is likely the last
time I challenge our class to charge out
into the world take what you've learned
at Carnegie Mellon and engage in the
pursuit of something greater than
ourselves and don't do it alone and
never waver in your commitment or in
your tenacity because I know we can and
because there are a few others better
equipped to do so right now than us
thank you so much for allowing me to
speak today and I am so excited to see
what we are all going to achieve thank
you